what's up everybody Brandon Johnson here
again and today I wanted to go over a
couple of bluegrass guitar warm-up
exercises for soloing out of the G
position this is more of kind of a
beginner or intermediate oriented lesson
and what's great about playing out of
the G position is you can really just
Capo up to really any key you want to
whether it's g a b b flat and these kind
of warm-up exercises will still apply to
all those keys as long as you're using a
capo so we're going to be using the G
Major scale for these exercises and
we're going to be using the G Major
scale out of the open position so what
that means is we're going to be playing
a lot of open strings when we play our G
Major scale so let's take a look at a
basic G Major scale and we're going to
be playing this with just down Strokes
to start
[Music]
and then back down
so that's your Basic G Major scale and
the idea here with this is we're going
to kind of get ourselves warmed up
before we practice or before we even
play a show or or just jam with some
other Pickers it's a good idea to kind
of get your fingers moving get your
right hand and your left hand sort of
warmed up to get the blood flowing but
then also there's a certain element of
getting the actual physical guitar
warmed up as well that's that's
important the guitar will actually
acclimate to your body heat as you're
kind of playing it and it'll sort of
stay in tune better and it'll actually
improve the tone of the instrument as
well so this Basic G Major scale using
only down Strokes is a good starting
point so let's dial up the metronome
here and let's do a couple of speed
building exercises with a basic G Major
scale one two three four two two three
four
[Music]
one two three four two two three four
and the idea with these exercises is not
only just to get you warmed up but also
to work on your timing so you really
want to pay attention to the
subdivisions the distance between the
notes and really focus on on playing
musically even though you're playing
just a straight scale it's important to
try to play that scale in a musical away
whatever that means to you and to me
what that means is is playing it
melodically as if I'm playing that song
as its own Melody for example instead of
just a scale and using the metronome to
really
create emphasis with your playing in
other words trying really hard to have
really good timing which will then allow
your your Melodies to be more effective
so we just got done playing the G Major
scale at three tempos with quarter notes
so let's play that same G Major scale
now but instead of all down Strokes
let's add alternate picking into the mix
so alternate picking is where we're
going to start on a down stroke and then
we're going to play an upstroke and
we're going to alternate back and forth
between down strokes and upstrokes one
two three four two two three four
[Music]
foreign
one two three four two two three four
[Music]
so right now we're kind of working on
both our left hand and our right hand
technique and specifically regarding our
right hand technique with this alternate
picking it's really important to kind of
try to make the volume between your
downstrokes and your upstrokes the same
what that has to do is is pressure you
want to feel the pressure of
the pick
impacting the string you want that
pressure to be kind of even
foreign
to have like a nice even volume so when
you combine
the alternating picking with a nice even
volume and really good timing you're
well on your way to you know really
having an effective delivery with your
playing so we just did alternating
picking with the G Major scale on
quarter notes let's do alternating
picking now on eighth notes one two
three four two two three four
[Music]
foreign
one two three four two two three four
[Music]
foreign
let's try that same pattern now with
16th notes because in bluegrass music
you play a lot of 16th notes so let's
one two three four two two three four
one
[Music]
two three four two two three four
all right so now let's move to a little
bit more of an intermediate level scale
warm-up exercise and we're going to work
with something here called scale folding
and scale folding is where the notes of
the scale sort of fold into each other
and I'll demonstrate what that means
here in a second and we'll try the scale
folding technique in groups of three so
the first group of three is going to
sound like this
so you're going to play those three
notes and then you're gonna add one more
interval to that
starting on the same note that you just
started with
[Music]
and then from there you're gonna
start instead of starting on the root
note you're going to start on the open a
and you're going to continue in that
fashion
[Music]
so you're going to continue on in that
way leaving out One Tone each time so
what that does is it allows you to take
the seven tones of the major scale and
make it sound like it has a lot more
motion to it one two three four two two
three four
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
one two three four two two three four
okay okay
[Music]
all right so let's use that same scale
folding technique now over eighth notes
and this time we're going to try to
ascend which is where we go from the low
register to the high register on the on
beat and then we're going to kind of
descend on the offbeat one two three
four two two three four
[Music]
thank you
one two three four two two three four
[Music]
all right now let's really challenge
ourselves and see if we can play this
exact same pattern now with 16th notes
one two three four two two three four
[Music]
foreign
one two three four two two three four
[Music]
thanks for checking out this lesson
today if you'd like to download the tab
sheet for free head on over to my
website Brandon Johnson guitar.com I
also offer an all-access membership
where you can get access to every single
lesson that I've ever made so head on
over to the website and check it out see
you there
[Music]